yeah got to get those vitamins in my
system
all right
let's do it
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen
welcome back to Yo absolutely
favorite podcast
[Music]
[Music]
what's up y'all back again ripping with
Griffin kind of somber today uh I'm
gonna talk about it my you know you guys
know my mom has dementia she like took
off today like just went walking on her
own so we had to call the police so that
was the whole thing so I'm in my
feelings about that and we're trying to
get her into this drug trial and I just
want to talk about
the placebo effect plus I have some real
world advice from a grown ass man so
welcome back
[Music]
this is
[Music]
all right y'all welcome back to riffing
with Griffin here we are in the house
within with a girl
but before we start
um where is it uh shout outs to our
sponsor door Dash
love doordash but wish she didn't have
to pay delivery fees well dreams do come
true during summer of doordash you get
zero delivery fees and members enjoy
exclusive new offers every week that's
50 off your first order up to 15 value
with code Griffin terms apply
thanks for joining the show guys
welcome back to riffin with Griffin
starring Eric Griffin I should have done
that during the intro uh make sure you
subscribe guys subscribe share uh all
that good stuff hit the notifications
trying to build the show I'm putting a
lot of content now on Facebook and
Instagram so make sure you guys check
that out uh on Twitch every day you know
I love playing I'm on Call of Duty and
I'm playing a little fortnite now
decided to get into some fortnite so
make sure you check me out on that and
news I got an upcoming show this weekend
and here we go
what's up y'all this is Eric Griffin and
I'm coming to Creek and Kate Austin
Texas I'm coming your way July 15th 15th
July 16th that's this week Friday and
Saturday come check me out do my thing I
might even bring the singing Mike who
knows but you know who it is
[Music]
all right well yeah I did a little
commercial of my own right
ah
uh anyways y'all thanks for joining the
show and John thank you so much for the
Super Chat doing something different at
the end of the show I got some dope
beats I get I've gotten in the past from
some great musicians out there and
producers who make music so uh I'm just
gonna recap the show with a little
freestyle you know how I do I'm 50 so
it's that's how we do it dad Style
so anyways
um thanks for uh being here
yeah man kind of in a mood you know what
I mean don't want to bring everybody
down but you know it is what it is you
know life happens I do this live
um you know other shows they do you know
they pre-record they have big time
guests or whatever but this is how we do
it on Richmond with Griffin
so you know I get a call as you guys
know I've talked about this in the past
but my mom has dementia
I don't know if anybody's dealing with
that
in your life but man it's something else
man
um I even want to just look it up and
see like what was the clinical you know
they say like dementia is not a specific
disease but it's rather a general term
for the impaired ability to remember
think or make decisions that interferes
with
doing everyday activities Alzheimer's
disease is the most common type of
dementia the dimension mostly affects
older adults it's not a part of normal
aging
um
man you know it's tough I know if
there's people out there that are
dealing with this that they dealt with
with their grandmothers and stuff like
that you know I'm 50 years old so like
my mom's like 81 she just turned 81 you
know she's had this for a few years now
and it's like you know it's it's a tough
thing to do with dementia is one of
these things that's so difficult to deal
with because of what it does to the
loved ones you know I wish I could
understand what it does to the person I
I do feel like because my mom's dementia
is mild when it was first diagnosed that
it's probably very confusing I remember
you know my parents live out in Oxnard
and I remember you know my mom thinks
she's someplace else okay so I remember
where I'm talking we're at lunch in the
little cafeteria area where they live
and you know we're talking with other
people and I say how did you you know
they I said how did I drive up there and
I was like oh I took PCH you know and I
saw my mom because she had recognized
edition of like well PCH is in
California you know that's a coat why
would you take PCH because she thinks
she's somewhere else you know what I
mean so I know that that's confusing and
probably to hear other people talking
about stuff so that's probably making
her confused you know and I could tell
sometimes you know my mom's very
stubborn I mean I get that from my mom
I'm stubborn as well and I could tell
that like you know she's you know trying
to fight you know and it's like I'm not
she don't want to feel crazy and all
that kind of thing and it's like that's
the thing they don't know they think
you're crazy you know their thing she's
like what are you talking about PCH you
ain't on PCH I could be on PCH when
we're over here you know what I mean so
that's a difficult part so and I know
how it is and I've gotten this question
from people uh they ask they'll be like
hey how do you deal with this or if
people that are first starting to get
with this it is hard
because this person that you know uh
that you've known for so long of your
life is essentially not the same person
anymore and that's difficult to like
understand and then you know you have
your own selfish feelings about like you
know like you don't want to deal with it
or you see this and you're like oh my
God then you just have awful thoughts
sometimes because you sometimes you
think to yourself like man maybe you
want this to just end or you you know
like you try to avoid or like I mean
there's so many different thoughts that
you go through and it's like it's hard
to under it's hard for say someone else
to understand because you know you know
they don't get it if they don't you're
not living it you don't get it so you
know and things do things
affect people in different ways and
people grieve in different ways people
process in different ways you know
sometimes you might see somebody who's
like something going through something
really terrible but they're they seem to
be keeping themselves busy some other
people they stay indoors and they don't
do anything or some people are very
active or some people like
some people try to crack a lot of jokes
uh you ever seen that kind of a response
where some serious stuff's going on and
that's just a nervous response I mean we
all respond to things in different ways
man you know so it can be like extremely
difficult uh to process and I'm just
telling you out there however you're
processing it you're not wrong you know
you're not alone out there I mean it can
just be so heart-wrenching you know it
could just be heartbreaking so like I'm
in a situation now where like every time
I see the phone and I see my
stepfather's uh name I just think the
worst you know and sure enough this
morning it was early I get a call and
he's like your mom took off on me again
and this has happened before so you know
she don't know where she is she thinks
she does you know she thinks her
grandmother's house is down the street
you know so she's like I'm gonna go to
Grandma's on my own Mike's sleeping I'm
just gonna go
you know and then you know we have to
call the police and it's just like I'm
you know I'm just hoping that there's
nice people out there the last time this
happened she fell down because my mom's
getting older so she's a little feeble
you know so it's hard for her to walk so
she's just walking and walking and
walking and she don't know where she is
she's like how come I haven't got here
already or or you know I don't know
what's going on in her head so this time
they found her at a Starbucks you know
you know shout out to Starbucks you know
what I mean
so now I'm thinking I got to get some
kind of like tracking thing you know
because she has a phone but she don't
always take the phone she don't even
understand the phone so I gotta find
some kind of device or something like
that I can put like we can make a little
bracelet or a little like necklace she
can wear all the time or something we
put something in her shoes you know what
I mean the shoes she wears all the time
we got to do something like that so I
know there's things out there and if you
you know if you have something like that
in the comments please uh you know
whatever whoever whatever you have
um
you know what I mean so just put that if
you if you know so I mean it's it's like
damn man
um you know what I mean like it's just
one of those things man and it's such a
weird disease so like you know my mom
thinks her grandmother's alive you know
and at first I tried to like try to you
know you try to like fight you try to
argue you try to like rationalize you
try you're not supposed to do that I
didn't know at first you know I talked
about this on stage you know because
it's like at first you know you know
tell them I'm telling my mom like like
you're you're
you're 78. grandma would be
135 years old like what are you talking
about Grandma ain't alive you know and
she's fighting yes she is you know and
so then I realize you're not supposed to
do that you know what I mean
um but it's this is what I'm saying
about how it's weird so she was talking
about her uncle which is like her
grandmother's son right and she's just
talking about him oh I remember him
and then she goes like this she goes oh
but he's oh he's probably long dead I
mean he'd be like 99 years old at this
point
and I'm looking at it and I'm thinking
to myself so in your brain you know that
your grandmother's son should be dead
but not his mom you know what I mean so
like
as we sit here and try to rationalize
like how like how come she don't
understand it's just a difficult thing
right
so I don't know
oh no man I just you know I don't know
if I'm even handling it the right way
it's like shout out to my stepdad he's
just the salt of the earth because he's
just out there dealing with it on a
daily basis
and I'm honestly I know I'm not doing as
much as I can I mean they live kind of
like it's not conveniently close
you know and I just I'm traveling I just
got married I'm just you know what I
mean you're like you're just trying to
live your life you know what I mean and
it's just like you know so I don't know
I I just I have to like I'm trying to
process this better so for you people
out there that are dealing with it too
and you find yourself being like ugh I
don't want to see my dad my grandma my
mom I don't I just I don't want to see
them like that I totally know how you
feel and it's a normal feeling and we
just have to like
look past the negative and um look past
our own selfish you know how things make
us feel and you know you think of it in
reverse like how would it
how would it feel
you know if something was going on with
me how would it make her feeling and
what would she want to do and you know
what I mean so it's like you just have
to like find ways to like cope and it's
just like that's why you got to stay
healthy man you know got to work out you
gotta take your vitamins you gotta sleep
right you know and that's the hardest
thing to do when your life is like
feeling like some major uh thing is
going on in your life it's like how do
you still stay healthy you know a really
good friend of mine is dealing with
something you know her you know she just
had a baby and now she's pregnant and
she got the news that her husband has
like a terminal cancer
and it's like oh my God what do you do
you know so I'm trying to tell her like
you know you really now it's like she's
in a position where she got to take care
of herself she cannot afford to
be depressed and be sad and have that
energy affect her new baby if you
believe in that and it's like man how do
you stay focused and present and you
know remember to eat remember to sleep
because it's like bigger than you you
know what I mean it's like damn I mean
life man it's like when you're young you
think you're Nothing's Gonna affect you
and and you think like man I could
conquer the world or like whatever is in
front of you is the most important thing
in your life you know whether it be
school or a job or like some kind of
like one-time thing that you're doing
and you're just like oh my God this is
the most important thing in the world
you know
um and then like as you get older and
you just that you re-prioritize and then
like look for me it's like I just got
married so I'm sitting here like man I
have to take care of myself you know
it's like oh my friend was saying like
oh if the doctor like the best case
scenario is he has 20 years left you
know and to them because they're young
they're like oh my God this is so
terrible but then I started to think
well [ __ ] I'm 50. I mean do I have 20
years left like should my should I sit
here with my wife and be like babe I
probably only have 20 years left what
are we going to do so it's like no you
have to live life to the fullest no
matter what
easier said than done but just like
really start to think about it you know
I and I'm really thinking about that you
know what I mean so it's like you know
yeah you know I got my multivitamins I
got my rowing machine downstairs I got
you know you know as you get older you
start taking all kind of stuff
that she didn't think you needed to take
you know
I got my Omega
you know what I mean got my Omega-3
you know 675 milligrams of Omega-3
taking my ollipop my probiotic soda
you know what I mean y'all
got my Uber Kunal uba Kunal Uber I don't
even know how to say it I never know how
to say names or what anything is
but I had to get a new bottle of this
stuff Rachel goes to Sprouts she's the
one that got me into that
because she's always you know just
looking fresh and young you know she
looks just like I see pictures of Rachel
when she was like 17 and then side by
side I'm like God damn you look the same
you know so that's because she like
doesn't she doesn't eat dairy and she
doesn't like bread she's you know it's
like all these things that she just
naturally did that is probably affected
and she sleeps forever Rachel if she got
a day off this woman will sleep 10 hours
right I see people in the chat I know
you're gonna die no matter what so it's
like
you know we should live life to its
fullest until that actually happens
you know what I'm saying
so I don't know so anyways
um one of the things I wanted to talk
about today is uh so you know there's a
lot of drug trials
um you know there's you know there's
there's always a disease or something
and they're trying to solve it they have
they they have the drugs they've gone
through all the tests and now they're at
the point where it's like human trials
and so you know we uh there's a lot of
drug trials for dementia Alzheimer's
because they're really trying to solve
this disease you know and I shout out to
the people doing this so UCLA has this
drug trial and you know we my mom went
on an interview to do it so she had to
go on it my mom's birthday was on July
4th
and you know so she's about to turn 81
and so like 80 is to cut off so they had
to get her in before so she went did the
tests and all this stuff so we're trying
to see so but here's what I'm trying to
talk about today is like and I tried to
talk about this on King of the sting but
these idiots you know what I mean like
these come you know what was I trying to
be serious with those clown faces love
them though but
when you're in a drug trial
part of it is
not everyone gets the drug so it's like
a blind study where some people have the
drug and some people have a placebo
and so I thought about that
um
and it didn't make sense to me because
isn't the placebo effect and if there's
doctors that listen or you know a doctor
I would love to hear what someone has to
say about this scientists and stuff like
that so I'm gonna give you my Layman's
understanding of what I think a placebo
effect is and so so you have a placebo
and so maybe the person
that has the whatever thing it is you
know they elect to go into this drug
trial they're not given the drug they're
given a placebo but in that process the
placebo effect they start to feel better
and whatever because they're in this
trial but to me it's because they know
they're in this trial so is it going to
cure cancer I don't think I don't I
don't know if that's ever happened I
mean I don't know if the placebo effect
has actually cured anything major but
who knows there's probably some of some
things out there you put there's
probably some story or two about
somebody it's like cured this and it was
just a you know sugar pill you know but
it has been shown to help with
depression and anxiety and things like
that when people think they're taking
something for it in their brain you know
those kind of brain things so
but my question about it and something
that gave me pause it's like my mom
doesn't know she has dementia people
with dementia and Alzheimer's don't know
they have it they they have they think
everything's fine they're living a
normal life
so
how would a placebo effect work
if they if they don't know they're in a
trial they you know how does it work I
get how it works with every other
disease
but how can it work with somebody that
don't even know something's wrong they
don't even know they're in a trial she's
just going with my stepfather down to
the thing you know I do remember the
first time we went to talk to the
doctors about it and it was me and my
stepfather and her and this was the
first time I really saw it firsthand
it's like you know the doctor's there
and he's like all right just talk about
it man and I was like you want me to
talk about this in front of her and he
was like well we have to do it so I'm
like well okay my mom has dementia I
said I think I didn't say that I said
well my mom thinks her grandmother's
alive and my mom was like what like you
know she was so confused she was like
what are you talking about and then they
did these tests you know in front of me
and so my stepfather and I are sitting
there with her and the doctor's asking
her certain questions and we're not
supposed to help and to see it like
because like when they have dementia
Alzheimer's a portion of their
personality is still there it's very
fascinating and my mom's sense of humor
is still intact she's so funny and
lovable and she's just you know very
sweet and she makes these like really
weird jokes and I'm like Mom you know
but when it comes to like the doctor's
like okay name me like you know animals
that start with the letter F or like you
know that kind of thing you know uh draw
a clock and and make it 11 30 you know
and it was like uh you know what is a
train and a bicycle have in common or
well it was all these kind of like you
know really like cognitive thinking
things that she just was lost you know
and I was like God damn this is tough
you know so
but then we left I remember this we left
a doctor she was still kind of there
like you know I could tell she was like
what's going on type of thing you know
and I'm like well well you know we had
to see the doctor and and then she
started to cry you know
she started to cry like as if she
understood something was wrong with her
you know but then shortly after
she was like are we going to Grandma's
house you know what I mean so in that
short moment I was like oh man you know
so anyways
so like I just don't know like what is
that you know so I had that poll up you
know uh I put this poll up because I
want wanted to see what people thought
like does the placebo effect
with dementia patient placebo effect
with dementia patients Works nope not
even sure so I guess the majority of the
people are not even sure you know uh and
the poll there you know and I totally I
mean I I I don't know either and then
like how am I supposed to feel you know
it's like there's a part of you that
wants to have hope that one of these
things this thing is going to work and
she's gonna get her personality and
she's going to get her Memories Back
so like it's a placebo effect for me and
my stepfather are we gonna sit here and
be like having hope and that she's gonna
like retain some of this you know so
it's like it's very it's a very like up
in the air type of thing and it's you
know it could be
it can be frustrating so I don't know if
um
you know however many other people out
there that are in chat right now if
you're dealing with this or if you've
dealt with it but it can be it's
something else man
um you know it's something else like you
know these these moments that you have
you know I mean sometimes it's just
funny and it's just like that's just the
way I deal with how I process because
you know I'm a comic you know what I
mean and I I like I laugh at tragedy
sometimes uh because I you know I look
at the Nuance of it uh but like I'm
driving with her one time and she like
every we passed a house and she goes oh
that house
see that house my grandmother took me to
that house when I first got to the
United States and I was like oh okay
which is like it couldn't it's not true
you know
two minutes later
oh see that house she's like
that house right there that's the house
my grandma brought after three houses I
was like which house is it woman I just
I don't know why I said that but it just
was like I was in that moment you know
because that's who I am you know I mean
if you guys see what I talk about on
here all the time and how I am like my
stand-up and stuff I'm like which house
is it you know and I shouldn't have said
that because she in that one single
moment she thought oh
then she was like oh never mind you know
and I was like uh I felt terrible you
know so I really try not to be like that
uh but man it's hard you know I just
really like stuff to make sense you know
I argue and you know I I go in about
things and so
when something just completely doesn't
make sense it's hard not to be like oh
you know that's one of the hardest
things to to deal with in that situation
so
a few people listening sorry I was
drinking a soda
um so call to action
if you are a doctor you're a friend of a
doctor you're a scientist you're a
friend of a scientist I don't know how
many scientists are watching my show but
I am curious about this I am curious
about
the power of the placebo effect there
was a Harvard study
uh actually on the website right now you
know there's a harvest study about the
power of the placebo effect it says
treating yourself with your mind is
possible but there's more to the placebo
effect than positive thinking and that's
very fascinating to me now you know they
go on to say you know your mind can be a
powerful healing tool when given the
chance the idea that your brain can
convince your body a fake treatment is a
real thing the so-called placebo effect
and thus stimulating healing has been
around for Millennia now science has
found that under the right circumstances
a placebo can be just as effective as
traditional treatments
very fascinating the placebo effect is
more than positive thinking believing a
treatment or procedure will work it's
about creating a stronger connection
between the brain and body and how they
work together says Professor Ted
kupchneck of Harvard so that sentence
right there is my question
uh it's about so what he says there it's
about creating a stronger connection
between the brain and body and how they
work together
so to me if you're talking about a
dementia patient
their brain and body are not working
together at all anyway so how does that
how could that possibly work so my point
is
if you're a dementia patient if you're
you know you're you're taking your
grandma whoever in for this dementia
trial drug trial I feel like once they
do the blind you know like pennies out
of a hat or whatever whatever they're
taking to figure out who's getting the
drug and who's not I think the people
that they know are getting a placebo
they need to let them go
but I just don't know
because maybe also
the treatment
like maybe the placebo effect is not
also just for the patient but for the
nurses and people treating them do they
know like who knows it's a placebo and
who and it's not is there a person that
knows and then there are other people
that don't know I would really love to
like you know this is if I'm gonna have
a guest I'd love to have like some sort
of medical guest on just to discuss this
just to be like you know how does this
work
um so
it's really it's really interesting
[Music]
um
you know oh and by the way it says it
goes
experts have concluded that reacting to
a placebo is not proof that a certain
treatment doesn't work but rather that
another non-pharmaceutical mechanism may
be present I mean do you believe in the
mind and body
uh you could control your mind and body
uh you know can you self-heal I mean you
know you get into like some Fufu about
like you know meditating and um
breathing and all this kind of stuff and
I you know I think there is something to
it I mean
I have like bad lower back pain
so I just I started doing like these
lower back pain stretches and I do it
every day I do it twice a day and
man when you're stretching I should show
you one day I should show you guys my
lower back stretching routine maybe I'll
do that on my podcast you know just some
other content because I don't know I'm
trying to get I need to get up to 100
000 followers because I mean viewers
right
I mean can I do it I don't know I love
my little fan base but it's like hey I'm
trying to grow what is it going to take
to grow y'all should give me some real
ideas not just criticism just give me
some ideas but anyways
you know so I do these back exercises
but I know I tell you this when you're
stretching
the thing that makes stretching work the
most is breathing like when you inhale
and then you exhale while you're in the
middle of a stretch it it enhances the
stretch in a way you go deeper it's
almost like you're me like you're make
you're pushing your body in a very
relaxed way to do the stretch even more
it's really fascinating you know and so
like I find myself like you know
breathing
or even when I find myself upset I take
some meditation breaths you know we
should let's take some meditation
breaths right now you know we should do
that as a little riffing with Griffin
yoga sesh right now so it's like you
take in for four out for six in for four
out for six so
and just even doing it one time
there's something about it you know
to calm yourself down to like
Focus your energies and so then you get
it then when when people talk about this
though and then they start to talk about
it in a way that sounds like you go you
sound like a crazy person you know when
you start talking about chakras and you
know what I mean they start getting into
this weird
weird that's when you start to go off
the rails but man just start with yoga
start with breathing start with like
you know if you're doing just a regular
even if you're just stretching your calf
like I stretch and then you run you find
out when you have like lower back pain
you find out all the other muscles that
are connected that are that could
alleviate some pain so like when you
have back pain you gotta stretch your
hammies and your calves because all that
tightness pulls your muscles on your
back and that's part of like
making your back hurt so I have to do I
get every morning I stretch my calves I
do like 30 seconds each calf I do it a
couple times and then I do like a sort
of like uh what is it Mountain pose well
but I'm not all I use the bed and then I
you know stretch my hammies and then I
go down on the ground and I do like the
the cat pose I do that and then two
different types of cat poses and then
I'll do this pigeon stretch where you
know you put your leg underneath your
you stretch your leg you you bend your
leg in front of you and then you bend
over your leg you you know and then you
stretch out your your sciatic all that
stuff man talk about instant back pain
relief listen to me instant back pain
relief so you know but in that process
I'm starting to feel like you know and
here's one you're not talking about
anything I don't care so this is
something too I want you guys to because
so you guys gonna think this this is
like a nasty topic but listen to me
when you're on the toilet
and you feel
constipated or you feel like you're not
getting it out
do this trust me
do your meditation breaths what you do
is you breathe in
and then when you breathe out release
all of the tension because you don't
realize how much when every day even
right now you're holding your bladder
and your insides you're keeping it tight
you're holding it in so you can't so you
don't just you know poop yourself like
you know at Starbucks or pee your pants
so you're always locked up so when your
body is locked up like that sit on the
toilet
and meditate
breathe and tell you if if you could
control your body if let's say you could
control your insides and I believe that
you can think about what that would feel
like and release
and just sit there for as long as it
takes I'm telling you and you just
breathe in breathe out and every time
you breathe out you release
and you release and I'm telling you your
butthole is going to do stuff that you
didn't even know was gonna happen you're
gonna be like oh it's just gonna like do
stuff on its own you'll just be sitting
there all of a sudden
[Music]
you'll be like oh man it worked like
without you even doing anything like
your body's working on its own it's
finally like the the the faucet is open
and boom and then you know and there you
go down you know what I mean so you know
I'm just saying there's something to
that so but anyways like I say shout out
to everybody who like if you know
somebody who you might even know
somebody who like
um studies this I just would like to
talk to somebody about dementia patients
and a placebo effect guys
all right let's get back to I gotta pay
some bills
door Dash door Dash
um so right now they're talking about
they they have a special okay so
ordering all your summer Essentials with
dash pass by doordash is a great way to
get everything that you need because you
can get anything from doordash you can
order stuff like you know you get
shampoo all that kind of stuff that you
need from the store that you didn't
necessarily get and then you went and
you forgot some stuff you can use door
Jazz Summer's in full swing and the
celebration begins during the summer of
dash pass by doordash with weekly
members only offers and new items
released every week you can shine bright
and feel cool all season long
say hello to Summer savings during the
summer of dash pass from doordash with
zero delivery fees exclusive items and
more than 25
000 members only offers Nationwide with
your dash pass by doordash members can
save an average of four to five dollars
on every order you place
for delivery or pickup shine bright
during Dash doordash's summer dash pass
and get 50 off your first order up to 15
value use promo code Griffin at checkout
when you spend 12 or more that's fifty
percent off your first order up to
Fifteen dollar value when you sign up
for doordash during summer of dash pass
using promo code Griffin don't forget
that's code Griffin
g-r-i-f-f-i-n for 50 off your first
order up to Fifteen dollar value
um dash pass benefits only on eligible
orders that meet the minimum subtotal
terms apply
all right
um
I hear like a buzz I don't know what
that is
all right I think that's my mic I don't
even know whatever
um let me plug this back in so
um
oh yeah thank you doordash
thank you Lord Ash thank you
all right guys so now I got some
wait oh here it is
real world advice from a grown ass man
okay
I got some real world advice from a
grown ass man I usually put the things
on the screen but I like again I didn't
get to do it today because I just was
like guys I was you know I was I was
going through it today so
I got let me just I got it on my screen
so I'll tell you some of the ones I
gotta look through some of them some of
them are good some of them I already
answered on
um Instagram I like to do it on
Instagram so make sure you check out my
Instagram at Eric Griffin
uh you know let's go to Instagram so you
can see
you know see my Instagram because I've
I've done some I'm putting more content
from my uh Facebook I'm sorry from my
podcast on Instagram so make sure you
guys check that out you know more
regularly if you're not already
following me on Instagram check me out
on Instagram y'all you know I got a
bunch of like stuff from the podcast and
just you know more pictures stuff from
my gaming and stuff like that so you
know check me out on uh uh Instagram
even if Instagram's even still a thing
um okay so let's get to it so
let's see what's some good ones here
going to college
how should I socialize with people it's
it's a different dynamic
I mean yeah you know high school when
you're leaving high school it's a
certain bubble you have in high school
so there's like certain restrictions and
stuff that you have because your parents
are telling you where you can and cannot
go maybe you have your first job you
just got a car but there's a lot of
rules and restrictions and so when
you're dealing with people and these are
people you know these are people you
spend hours with daily a lot of times
your high school friends but when you go
to college it's different uh the main
difference is that you have freedoms no
one's watching over you
so it's that's the only difference in
Dynamic but just be yourself you know
you just go out you meet people remember
these are people that are pretty much
like-minded they're out here trying to
learn and get a degree and uh you know
be an adult just like you so you already
have something in common when you first
get to college so if you're living in
the dorms especially look around these
are people that are just like you so you
know get out of your shell open up and
just be like hey man can we uh I'd love
to you know talk or you know you're
gonna meet women or meet men whatever
your thing is and romantically I'm
saying and you know it's just it's just
a whole new experience but just let it
happen and just remember that you're not
like that different from all of these
people they're going through the same
feelings as you you're you know they're
leaving home and they're living on their
own for the first time too or they're
they're going to be going to college and
seeing like all these different adults
and and making choices and decisions
that are going to affect the rest of
their life just like you so just uh be
open to that and see see where it goes
hmm good luck
all right
um
let's see they got a lot of silly ones
how do I end my relationship with
chocolate
[Laughter]
hey man we all got addictions you know
or we got things that we like you know
it's like you know chocolate sugar sodas
Donuts or you know eating too much red
meat drinking too much coffee moderation
everybody just try to find some
moderation that's the hardest part you
know that is the hardest part
here's somebody trying to be a new comic
trying to find the nerve to get on stage
and tell some jokes any advice on
powering through I mean one of the
number one fears
still to this day and one of the the one
of the top fears is public speaking even
over death I think probably speaking is
over death so I get it the only way to
do it is to do it I mean I do recommend
taking a class if you can find some sort
of like improv class or comedy class or
comedy acting anything like that where
you have a safe comfortable environment
with a teacher and you learn how to like
get in front of people and you know just
express yourself in a way you haven't
done before it's actually a very fun uh
safe environment very uh loose very
comfortable environment that you can
learn to be vulnerable if you're if
you're someone that doesn't need that
and you're just ready to go you think
you could do it go do it find an open
mic sign up and just do it you know or
you know you might know a friend who has
like a you know they're doing like a a a
a a a Christmas you know party for a job
and you're like hey can I go tell some
jokes like you can you can create things
on your own and just try to just just
get out there and do it that's my best
advice for you just get out there and do
it
this one was tough and by the way I
always say this
um I'm not an expert I'm just giving you
my thoughts on your questions but if you
do have some serious issues going on and
some traumas I highly recommend therapy
uh therapy is great man uh it it's
therapy is not just about
[Music]
um
you know solving your problems is about
organizing your thoughts and seeing
patterns of why you feel the way you
feel with an expert who recognizes these
patterns who studies these things and
who's able to see hey this is caused
from this and this and you see these
root causes and you might have some you
come up with some coping mechanisms to
help you power through it may not solve
it but you can have a better
understanding and that's why I highly
recommend therapy if anybody has any
questions in chat if you have a like a
real question in chat I will be more
than happy to uh you know give you some
advice in chat too so the reason why I
said that about therapy is I got one
right here I just found out my child is
a bully I have no idea how to parent
that any advice I am not a parent I hope
to be one and I guess that's a fear that
all parents have is that their kid is
going to be terrible right so that's a
tough thing so what are you supposed to
do you know and I think it's just a
matter of like some open communication
just like really the being more involved
probably
uh you know finding out how this kid is
feeling some therapy sounds like some
counseling is in order there and uh
seeing what your part in helping
facilitate uh you know a better
lifestyle or to find out what's going on
why why is this person lash now why is
your kid lash now what's going on you
know you actually you probably want to
make sure it isn't because of you or is
it because uh you know or you might find
that there's nothing you nothing you did
you know I don't know you know what I
mean I think this is just the hardest
part that there's no manual there's no
like how do you raise a kid right you
know there's people that come from
really great homes and they turn out to
be
you know bad things happen so hopefully
it's just a phase and you know you
obviously you found out so you want to
get involved so that's the best part
about you know that's the best thing you
could do as a parent right now is just
be involved get involved
so re even reaching out to some strange
comedian is like the first step but now
it's time to be like hey maybe it's time
to go to the school find out who the
counselors are the guidance counselor
the homeroom teacher someone there to be
like hey this is going on I'm finding
this out what can we do get some help
you know it's okay we're not you know
again your kid doesn't pop out with a
manual you know what I mean it's not
like you know you do like it's like
you're doing an unboxing you know what I
mean like you're in the operating room
like you're like my wife's about to have
a baby or I'm about to have a baby the
baby's coming out and then it comes out
with like instructions like Ikea I wish
right then we could be like how to not
how to make sure your kid doesn't end up
on the pole or how to make sure your kid
doesn't end up as a bully it doesn't
work like that so it's okay to reach out
and ask for help
okay it's okay
all right
um
all right here here's a good one too and
this is like you know I'm in a
relationship so this is like one of
these kind of things that you realize
that happened in relationships how do I
tell my 25 year old fiance her
relationship with parents is unhealthy
manipulative codependent oh man it's
tough
you know I guess when you have a
relationship with someone and it's
serious to the point where you're
engaged you have to remember that you
are building your own life
and you're building your own life your
own family you're starting your own
little community and yes these other
people in your life are there but you
have to find a way to strengthen your
relationship with each other
and do it with compassion you know
um you want you want to have a positive
outlook about it you don't want to be
like man your parents suck you want to
like encourage like hey maybe you should
make your own choice or hey have you
maybe we should try what do you think
you know encourage her to think for
herself by asking her questions by
asking for her advice by asking for her
what her thoughts are what her wants are
and try to work it out as a team as a
unit because that's what you're creating
and no matter who's your outside
influences and forces are in your life
no matter how important they are if you
can't create that bond with each other
to make sure that you got each other's
back then you're gonna have more bigger
problems than just worrying about her
parents who you think are this but hey
good luck
um
okay I already did that one uh okay
let's go to the next
um wait oops let's go to the next one
okay
all right uh
okay so here's this is one of these ones
where I would suggest some therapy for
this person but how do I get out of
depression I realize this it stems from
the absence of my father so I mean even
recognizing that is good so you're
already trying to recognize a root cause
so now it's like you know you know you
have to just try to deal with those
feelings by you know being a better
person yourself I don't know how old you
are if you have kids of your own maybe
you know my mom did that for me she had
terrible relationship with her parents
and she made sure that she didn't want
to be that way with me so she actually
spoiled me she went the complete
opposite way right so
this is one of these issues that you
need to talk out that you need to find
someone to talk to you know
betterhelp.com Griffin it's not a
sponsor today but I will say you know
it's very helpful to go to something
like that but that's one of those things
I mean if you really feel like that's
the reason that's a good start I just
feel like that's a good start uh you
you're already aware of it you're like
hey something's going on I'm feeling
this way and I think it's because of
this then hit that head on but don't sit
around and feel sorry for yourself don't
sit around and feel like you know don't
let the depression Fester you know it's
either you want to handle you want to
you want to do something about it it's
the reason why you even reached out like
this so continue that process and
continue to reach out because it is
something
um
this one's kind of funny am I a bad
person for getting a job Knowing damn
well I have to quit in one month
probably
you're not a bad person but you're
irresponsible you're not a bad person
but you're inconsiderate I find that to
be inconsiderate but I get it you gotta
do what you got to do you need the money
uh you maybe you like you went for this
job and you think this is my safety but
I'm trying to get something else and if
that comes through I'm gonna go that one
I'm Gonna Leave This one I get it and
I'm sure they can find someone else but
you know hey sometimes you make selfish
choices for yourself but just be aware
of it and you actually are you're
totally aware of it but I wouldn't say
bad person but it is an inconsiderate
act so just keep that in mind
um
I am the only family my husband has and
sometimes it's suffocating I feel
obligated to always include him
okay tough one
uh let me read that again I'm the only
family my husband has and sometimes it's
suffocating I feel obligated to always
include him I'll tell you what's wrong
with even how that sentence is written
is that you're assuming that you need to
do that and you're speaking for him
and that's just you being compassionate
and feeling for your husband and but
don't speak for them communicate with
them I think you should communicate I
think you should go to your loved one
and be like hey I know how it is you
don't have a lot of family and I'm here
for you but are you okay
are you good with me like going to hang
out with my friends are you good with me
like it and then and you might be
surprised your husband might be like
yeah cool go do you thanks for thinking
about me but I think that instead of
assuming how your loved one feels I
think it's important to actually
communicate how you feel they feel and
find out if that's true you know and
then and just having a conversation I
think is important you know it's super
important to have those types of
conversations to keep the the
communication going but don't assume you
know what I mean don't assume
all right let's see let's do a couple
more
um
all right here's another one about
depression I can't stop feeling like my
depression is selfish I have to put my
family first but it's getting hard I
mean that's some good self-awareness
right there
it's good self-awareness to be like hey
oh this is something that's me this is
my thing and I see how it's affecting
everyone else that's the first step in
you being like I need to do something
about this what do I'm gonna suggest get
you some therapy man
or you know start working out start uh
eating better start sleeping better so
make yourself feel better so you because
you want to be there for your family so
take the steps to do that but that's
good self-awareness I think it's a good
start so I'm gonna give you a pat on the
back for that so now follow through take
those steps all right
all right I see somebody in chat hey
Griff I'm 35 and I don't have a lot of
experience with women because of my
anxiety disorder my question is now that
I'm ready should I date younger or older
women
ah first of all ridiculous you start
with all this like really good
self-awareness and then you go into this
sort of shallow Zone
but you know what you're probably being
genuine it's a genuine thing
um
you know
here this is the thing
it don't matter like age really is just
the number
but but at first like find out like open
yourself up be vulnerable you're aware
of like the things that are going on
with you you're ready to handle it and
take care of it you're trying to keep it
under order you're trying to keep it in
control but you know you're looking out
for yourself and everyone around you by
doing that but now just open yourself up
you might meet a girl that's younger
than you you might meet someone that's
older than you it really is about their
experience just because someone's young
doesn't mean that they're like dominant
experience just because someone's older
means that they know it all I mean
everybody's got different levels of
stuff so you have to just be vulnerable
and open and find out so get yourself
out there just being open to that is
going to be a great thing that's what I
suggest that you do all right
anyways guys
um here's a new thing we're gonna start
doing on the podcast uh because I'm
trying to just you know again I'm trying
to try new things I'm trying to get out
here and so this is one of the things
I'm gonna try to do
um I get a lot of great beats uh my
buddy one of the kids that sends me
stuff is this kid named Chris you uh so
thanks for watching riffing with Griffin
uh remember I will be at the creek in
the cave in Austin Texas Friday and
Saturday this week come check me out
probably gonna do kill Tony on Monday
that's why I'm staying in Austin for an
extra day for that so just check me out
if you wanna if you're in the Austin
area but uh my boy Chris you sends a lot
of dope beats and this is one of those
beats
here on riffing with Griffin
okay okay
that's the show
watch the old man flow
what we talking about today
talking about it every day
placebo effect
do it work
I don't know
Eric Griffin with this sick ass flow
real world advice from a grown ass man
do it man
nothing people out
out
[Music]
terrific Griffin
[Music]
everybody's different living
check out my merch
with no Clerks
thanks for those super chats
said the beat make sure it's not black
I'm a rap on Happy
you in the chat just know your feet
eight years old
still got
it
Eric Griffin
Griffin Griffin
so that's how we're going to do it
I'm gonna recap the show with some with
some producer raps that people send in
thanks for watching we're from with
Griffin y'all and I will see you next
week